we're starting today with the topic of
abortion and this is a topic that there
was a period of time where it was less
of an issue there was less of a question
as to whether roe v wade was going to
remain the law of the land but now with
the supreme court potentially just weeks
away from issuing a ruling that would
uphold state restrictions on abortion
which would effectively reverse roe v
wade and the undue burden standard that
roe v wade contains which we will get to
that we are seen
expectedly as predicted more and more
states pass the types of laws that we
have seen from mississippi and from
texas and from elsewhere and the latest
state to do this is now oklahoma
oklahoma lawmakers have passed a
six-week abortion band a ban
modeled after the texas law that allows
civil enforcement that's another element
of this that is wacky retrograde stuff
civil enforcement of this law
and we will talk about why a six-week
abortion ban is effectively just a ban
on abortion
which unquestionably would violate roe v
wade's undue burden clause
except roe v wade may be reversed so
let's read about this first associated
press reporting oklahoma lawmakers
thursday gave final approval to a bill
modeled after the controversial texas
abortion law we knew every state that
wants to ban abortion is going to start
using that type of
the the they will use each other as
models
it is a law which allows private
citizens to take civil action against
abortion providers as individuals to
enforce the law
it's a sort of vigilantism in practice
the oklahoma heartbeat bill uh heartbeat
act senate bill 1503 would prohibit
abortions at the time when a physician
can detect early cardiac activity in an
embryo or fetus now understand
that it is not
it is
some like to say it is a heartbeat and
doctors often say
it's this is reflexive cardiac activity
to call it a heartbeat isn't even
accurate
that can be as early as six weeks into
pregnancy before many women even know
they are pregnant
the measure also provides exceptions for
medical emergencies the state senate
later thursday also passed house bill
4327
allowing private citizens to sue
abortion providers house bill 4327
however would prohibit abortions at any
point of pregnancy with exceptions for
medical emergencies or if the pregnancy
comes as the result of rape sex sexual
assault uh incest and is reported to law
enforcement so there's two parts of this
first we've already talked because of
the texas bill about this ability for an
individual to sue the abortion provider
it's another way to put in this case
it's not only the government between
doctors and their patients but random
people between doctors and their
patients if anybody can bring a civil
suit
but i want to focus in on the six six
week ban thing because the defenders of
this bill who want to at least pretend
about the rule of law which is roe v
wade established that generally speaking
women should have access to abortion
services and that no undue burden should
be placed on them in order to obtain one
now undue burden is a legal term that's
subject to interpretation and this is
where
i mean for 40 years that that phrase
undue burden has been subject to
interpretation by courts at all levels
but a six-week ban would absolutely
violate that and just think it through
many women most women don't know that
they're pregnant until four to five
weeks and what i mean by that is by the
time you miss a period and by the time
most home pregnancy tests can detect a
pregnancy
you're already considered to be four
or five weeks pregnant at minimum if you
at that point were to say hey
uh i got a prep positive pregnancy test
i'm going to go to my uh doctor my ob
gyn they will say oh yeah it's not
you're pregnant and it's the first week
they would say you are practically
speaking for potentially five weeks
pregnant at this point of time and and
if that if the requirement is no
abortions after six weeks
what that means is you need to say oh
well i need an abortion like tomorrow
and of course that is unreasonable that
is an undue burden even if one can
decide that quickly
to
if if most of you have tried to get
medical appointments lately you might
know you don't call and they don't give
you an appointment for tomorrow that's
generally a difficult thing to do so in
practical terms this is designed to be a
total abortion ban and it effectively
would be
by enforcing the six-week rule um we
will see
what happens in the supreme court this
bill this law will be appealed
based on current law it would be found
against roe v wade it would place an
undue burden on women you can't say six
week ban most women don't find out till
week four or five if they're pregnant
right so right now it would not it would
violate roe v wade
if in a few weeks the supreme court says
well we're we're okay with this law and
i believe it's mississippi
that would effectively overturn roe v
wade and that would make it so that laws
like this one in oklahoma and the one in
texas and others
likely would be allowed and uh of course
this then gets us into that situation
where what happens do people start
fleeing red states for blue states or
what is the right thing to do what is
the expected thing to do we don't know
yet but this is exactly what we do
go back to the beginning go back to my
shows
when i was saying hey you know guys i'm
worried this is this is 2016.
i'm worried
that there's too many people who aren't
taking seriously this issue of the
supreme court when they think about
trump versus hillary they go wow i don't
know if it's not going to be this person
if it's not going to be that person
hillary trump it's all the same and i
would say folks
you have no idea what a few conservative
supreme court picks by trump would do to
this country the first thing they will
do is they they're going to try to ban
abortion and then trump got one pick and
then he got a second pick and then he
got a third pick and then we knew
they're going to start the state level
bills the point of those bills is that
they be appealed
all the way up to the supreme court and
the supreme court might say no on the
first one
they might say no on the second one they
might not like some specific aspect of
the third one
but if they do it enough with this
right-wing court thanks to trump
defeating hillary and we have to be
honest that that's what put us in this
position
uh they may well overturn roe v wade we
may be weeks from the end of roe v wade
we are continuing to follow the 2022
midterms last week we
looked at both the democratic and
republican primary debates in the
pennsylvania senate race we will be
looking at another debate in that race
wednesday night i will be streaming the
republicans including mehmet oz and a
bunch of other wackos are going to be
debating and we'll be covering that live
but today i want to talk a little bit
about georgia georgia has a number of
interesting races and they involve
significant controversy in georgia
you've got the gubernatorial election
um in that uh that that is an important
race because of the role that georgia
played in 2020 and could play in 2024 in
the election and who is governor and
secretary of state a very big deal a
marjorie taylor green at this point
wildly perjuring herself
inciting an insurrection she is involved
in a race for reelection and there are
debates happening there as well and what
i want you to think about as you watch
some of these clips there were a number
of georgia debates over the weekend
we'll look at gubernatorial we will look
at also uh marjorie taylor green
um
they seem like saturday night live skits
and i'm not just talking about the
accents i know people in georgia in
certain parts there's a certain
education level where there's a certain
accent that's not what i'm talking about
these seem like characters out of a skit
where we are pretending to be
the most weaponized disinformed
caricatures of what it means to be an
american right-winger when we think of
how do you depict your typical american
right-winger in a film for a british
audience it would be like these people
let's go with the first clip this is
candace taylor
running for the g uh georgia uh
governor's race
and um
i i let's just listen i won't even
there's no there's really no way to
introduce this properly take a look i'm
going to put the constitution first and
i'm going to put jesus first every
single time
wait g your your guiding philosophy will
be jesus first
you're supposed to be a representative
of the state's civil government which is
a separation of church and state but she
openly says jesus
will be number one for her and we're
gonna fix our schools we're gonna get
rid of this anti-white racism and
oppression of our children of color
we're going to get and again children is
that is that a normal thing i don't want
to make fun of accents but are these
dude is that is that a normal thing
rid of a transgender manipulation and
we're going to ensure that boys are in
our girls bathrooms and girls are in our
boys bathrooms and people aren't being
raped and we're going to get rid of
kindergarten teachers men with beards
and lipstick and high heels teaching our
children we're going to get back to
being moral in georgia we're going to
put morality over money i'm candace
taylor i'm the one you've been waiting
for right
that is dark ages stuff is it even okay
to say i know sometimes people get mad
when you say dark ages but that that's
that's dark age of stuff that's
retrograde that's taking us back to you
know sometimes we say they want to take
us to 1955. with some of these people
it's almost like they want to take us to
1855 united states uh here's another
clip of candace taylor
talking about
what was going on all of the bad things
about
schools having been closed for a period
of time during the covet pandemic do you
do as governor would you push to help
address those issues dealing with
academics
absolutely it's gotten way worse because
of the plant pandemic because our
governor opened the state which was
great they didn't open the school now
did she say the planned pandemic i want
to go back because that that's another
wild conspiracy this is almost like
remember the the disinformation film
pandemic which argued it was all
planned by the globalist elite as alex
jones would say
thinly veiled anti-semitism by the way
because the the those globalished a
leach happened to be mostly jewish um
did she say the planned pandemic let me
listen it's getting way worse because of
the plant pandemic because our gift
plant
maybe it was just a stutter like it
could it's almost like she said the plan
pandemic let's listen in our opened the
state which was great they didn't open
the schools and so kids were at home for
a year
not ingrained in education and routine
children need routine and what we saw
happen is children with depression or
children that were being molested let's
talk about the hard stuff kids that have
been molested never have had a reprieve
they were molested day after day after
day and their parents were not teaching
them anything and so staying consistent
for one thing and after after school
programs and offering things to get them
yeah now i mean it is it is absolutely
true that
one of the things about being stuck at
home and we saw this with couples where
there's domestic violence
oftentimes leaving to work was when you
got a break from the domestic violence
that that is true but this sort of
framing
completely ignoring the actual
circumstances that were happening
medically imagine this is the governor
very very dangerous next we'll go to
from the georgia gubernatorial to
georgia 14th district there was a
republican primary debate the incumbent
in that seat is radical repugnant
reactionary republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene
and she was in a debate with jennifer
strahan
and her behavior was so childish
and so absurd
that the moderator actually had to cut
her mic because she just wouldn't stop
talking marjorie taylor green would not
stop talking conservative it takes
courage takes bravery to vote no to
bills that have poison pills inside of
them and things that should never be
passed and that's how the democrats
running congress that's how they're
writing bills right now and that is why
the voting record is
oh wow and then just a but
the the relief of the silence when
marjorie taylor green stops speaking
it's like you know when it it's like
you're a loud concert and it's just like
wow this is this is grading this is
grading and then all of a sudden it goes
silent and you go wow the the
tranquility
the tranquility sir of the silence
that is what i experience when marjorie
taylor green stops talking so that was
totally off the rails and then also in
the um congressional debate a guy named
eric cunningham is running and he tries
to deliver a statement about he will
also out jesus everybody else but he
weirdly like loses his train of thought
and just seems visibly confused they're
not sending their best my friends
cunningham i have strong core christian
conservative values and i want to
emphasize one word and they're christian
it's my faith that brought me into this
race and it's my faith that will lead me
when i go to congress to fight some of
the woke
transgender you name it um
agenda that they have they're trying to
force on us so he seems confused by his
own ideas and of course at this point
these are just these th these are just
buzzwords uh woke we're gonna fight woke
we're gonna fight transgender we're
gonna fight we
teacher trump now at his rallies saying
teachers shouldn't be allowed to teach
transgender
grammatically ambiguous for sure
uh morally morally depraved too so it's
actually the the 2022 midterms are
ramping up so quickly it's actually
tough to keep track i also wanted to
look at some clips from what's going on
in arizona in some of the primary races
there some of these primaries are this
week by the way and we'll talk about
that tomorrow tuesday but no shortage of
cuckoo for coco puffs people that
unfortunately i'd love to say these
people have no shot
but marjorie taylor green is in congress
now so we know they have a shot
let me know who you're most worried
about you can find me on twitter at
deepakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join
pacman.com lest anyone forget the david
pakman show is an audience supported
program we do the daily program that
you're listening to or watching right
now and we do an extra show called the
bonus show every single weekday for our
members you can sign up at
joinpackman.com you can also use the
coupon code wow22 to get yourself a tidy
little discount off of the cost of
membership
joinpakman.com is the place to sign up i
want to play a clip for you guys today
which i believe is a perfect example of
how
democrats should be dealing with these
neo-reactionary republicans in the house
of representatives and in the senate you
know what one of the conversations we've
had uh over the last few years
is that
even though the right has absolutely no
minimum standard whatsoever for what
they won't what they won't do what
they're not willing to do
we on the left shouldn't sink to their
level in the sense of telling straight
up lies
fabricating imaginary social issues
employing horrifying double standards uh
personal attacks
all of these different things but what
democrats should appeal to
is the public's sort of sense of justice
and emotions in order to get them to
understand the stakes of so many things
this is really one for the ages uh
congressman jamie raskin a democrat who
i'm a fan of i like jamie raskin i've
talked about him before
he ripped marjorie taylor green to
shreds after during a floor debate
supposedly about ukraine it's supposedly
about the brutal invasion of ukraine by
vladimir putin
she said nothing about it she instead
talked about the southern border and
made a whole bunch of other uh uh
completely fact-free claims
and jamie raskin takes her to task and i
wish more democrats in the house day in
and day out spoke about their extremist
republican colleagues in this way maybe
it could help them hold the house in
november take a look at this tact it's a
shame it's a tragedy i yield back the
remainder of reserve
gentlemen gentlemen's times expired
gentleman from pennsylvania reserves
gentlemen from maryland is recognized mr
speaker the united states of america
just witnessed witnessed the most
astonishing spectacle
we are here to debate
aid to the people of ukraine defending
themselves against a massive invasion by
vladimir putin
and his army
right
then
the minority puts up the distinguished
general lady from georgia who does not
mention ukraine once and by the way yes
i believe his use of the term
distinguished gentle lady about marjorie
taylor green i believe it's it's
tongue-in-cheek she does not mention the
thousands of ukrainian civilians who've
been slaughtered by putin's army she
does not mention more than 100 ukrainian
children who've been shot and killed by
the ukrainian army instead she talks
about a massive invasion
at the border a massive invasion which
their own speakers have said today
hundreds of thousands of people have
been apprehended it
that's very different from a military
invasion the one in ukraine of course
the gentlelady's not going to talk about
that
she had a lot to say the other day when
she heckled me continuously
when i came to the floor it was like the
rocky horror picture show in here with
her chanting about the russia hoax and
russia this and russia that
now she had the opportunity to tell the
world what her views about russia are i
put them out there exactly what she has
said she said that the aid that the
taxpayers of america are sending to the
people of ukraine to defend themselves
against vladimir putin and the russian
army falls into the hands of nazis i
want to see her proof
where's our evidence
she talks about
nato nazis
does my minority believe that our allies
in nato who are trying to defend the
people of ukraine are nazis has it come
to this
gentlelady talked about a massive
invasion we had a massive invasion of
our own chamber
and she continued to be a cheerleader
for the insurrection
this is exactly why i keep talking about
jamie raskin as someone that i would
support for president of course
depending on who else is running and
depending on what his platform would be
but in principle someone i would support
for president he's a constitutional law
professor he actually knows the
constitution marjorie taylor green loves
to talk about the constitution madison
cawthorne loves to claim that he's
defending the constitution they don't
know a damn thing about it this is
actually a constitutional law professor
raskin was a strong progressive activist
when he was in the maryland senate he
actually worked with republicans and
moderate democrats and got things done
he sponsored bills to get rid of the
death penalty in maryland to um
establish legal guidelines for
corporations to prevent them from raping
and pillaging the resources of the state
for their gain
he um worked he was on he was actually a
board member of fair vote which is an
interesting organization he sponsored
the first bill in the country for the
national popular vote i've talked about
so much which would be a way to
get rid of the electoral college without
actually having to change the
constitution he has this
marijuana reform all these different
things
this is what has to be done we need a
guy like raskin
talking about them as the extremists
that they are
wanting everybody to have health care is
not the left equivalent of supporting a
coup they have nothing to do with each
other and the level of extremism that we
are seeing from the right
requires and demands people like rask
and who can speak in this way now
raskin's not the only guy i've talked
about other people i like as well but
democrats need to be talking like this
more frequently and i'm glad to see him
do it you know one of the questions
we've been asking during this historic
anti-vaccine era
around the world because of the covet
vaccines is is it going to is anti-backs
going to start to bleed over
to more general
vaccine opposition
not just the covet vaccine what about
measles what about mmr and others and so
far the answer appears to be
unfortunately yes and this was very
predictable there's a good article in
the guardian measles cases surge nearly
80 percent
in the wake of coveted chaos with fears
other diseases could follow
unicef says viruses canary in the coal
mine that shows up
i think i think it's supposed to say
shows us the gaps in vaccination
campaigns for preventable illness
measles cases have surged nearly 80
percent worldwide amid disruption caused
by covet the un says
the coronavirus pandemic has interrupted
vaccination campaigns for non-covet
diseases around the world creating a
perfect storm that could put millions of
children's lives at risk
a measles is a disease caused by a virus
that attacks mainly children
vaccination uptake of at least 95
is the way to avoid it spreading some
countries fall short of that goal
somalia at just 46
there's also concerns about whether
yellow fever
could search
there are concerns about the ukrainian
invasion by russia
uh and the effect that that could have
the un says 57 vaccination campaigns in
43 countries have been postponed
so this is focusing on access
but the problem is
we saw outbreaks in the united states of
measles before the covet pandemic so the
point here is basically twofold because
of the pandemic there have been
campaigns of vaccination that have been
interrupted and they tell us how quickly
you can see outbreaks of something as
contagious as measles which in
particular uh is a problem among
children in the united states
a big
sort of battle line on the anti-vax
front is the vaccination of children
before we even had the covet vaccines in
this controversy we had some pretty good
size measles outbreaks
there was the disneyland one in
california there were some religious
sects in new york city where we were
seeing outbreaks there was one in italy
a couple others that i can't remember
these outbreaks were in part based on
the idea that parents didn't want to
vaccinate their kids now with measles
understand how critical that is
particularly when it's so contagious
that you need to be vaccinating 95
it is
a concern right now
that we are going to start seeing as
more and more kids come up for
vaccination boosters for other diseases
or as more and more kids are born and
it's time for get them to get the shots
that babies get in the first six months
we are almost certainly going to see
some more general vaccine hesitancy on
the basis of covet vaccine hesitancy and
it's going to lead to more of some of
these diseases and the measles
pre-covered example is one of the best
ones just small areas where they said i
don't i don't want to vaccinate my kid
against measles and they had outbreaks
and it's very serious for kids
um it could get very very bad and so
while on the one hand we're fighting the
vaccination battle on covid specifically
there's this other more general
anti-vaxx thing that is beneath the
surface and we've heard from some you
know look at the interviews we've seen
from trump rallies where parents say
well it's it's not just the covet
vaccine i'm getting my kids off of all
of these vaccines or sometimes they call
them they say they're injections they're
not strictly speaking vaccines
this could get very bad very quickly and
we should be paying close attention to
the numbers from all over the world
we'll have uh more about this story on
our instagram make sure you're following
us there at david pakman show we'll take
a quick break we'll look at the white
house correspondents dinner we'll look
at a few other things be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show i don't really care
very much about the white house
correspondents association dinner this
is a dinner that donald trump would not
attend but that typically presidents go
to and you schmooze with the people who
are covering your presidency jokes are
told they bring in comedians this year
the comedian was trevor noah i i it's
not really an event i care about and i
thought about covering it live and then
decided i don't even really care about
it i don't think i'm going to cover it
but there are a few interesting moments
from it that i want to go over and um
these are from joe biden now of course
joe biden didn't write this stuff but it
doesn't matter the points that that are
made here are interesting and they're
pretty funny one aspect of this that was
uh sort of controversial was that to go
to this event you had to provide proof
that you were not only double vaccinated
against coven but also boosted and fox
news has a table or at least one table
maybe multiple tables at this event and
of course on air fox news has run
significant anti-vaccine interference
hilariously they were there and joe
biden pointed out one of the great
things about this event is you can look
at the people sitting at the fox news
table know
that regardless of what they're saying
on air they are vaccinated and boosted
check this out
we're here to show the country that
we're getting through this pandemic plus
everyone had to prove
they're fully vaccinated and boosted
so if you're at home watching this
and you're wondering how to do that
just contact your favorite fox news
reporter they're all here
vaccinated and boosted
all of them
and there it cuts to peter ducey one of
the main antagonists of white house
press secretary jenn
i mean listen it is on it is on the one
hand a a relatively kind of cheap joke
and obvious line
and the people who most need to hear it
probably aren't watching this event but
it is a great reminder that many of the
people
making you question
whether you should go and get the covet
vaccine
by using spurious claims and
non-evidence-based uh reporting
they are vaccinated they're vaccinated
and you could say well they're
vaccinated by force because they needed
to in order to well not really i mean
fox news had an option for not being
vaccinated you could choose to test
daily if that's what you wanted to do
but they are making you hesitant to go
and get a vaccine
they are vaccinated they are having a
good time at the white house
correspondence dinner so that that was a
good moment now for all we know they i
don't know they bought fake vaccine
cards seems risky as a member of a
prominent media outlet to use a fake
vaccination certificate or card to get
into a white house correspondents dinner
so probably not laura ingram by the way
reportedly was there she's been a major
anti-vaxx voice this confirms if indeed
she was there that she's double
vaccinated as well as uh boosted joe
biden with another funny line talking
about the plague and trump i won't spoil
it for you i'll just play it for you the
first time
president attended this dinner in six
years
it's understandable
we had a horrible plague
followed by two years of coving
i know it's kind of cheesy but i i like
it
[Applause]
just imagine if my predecessor came to
this dinner
this year
now that
would really have been a real coup if
that occurred
i don't know guys i know a lot you know
this this is not a policy thing but i i
liked what biden did i thought it was
the exact right sort of tone uh he also
and i mean he is taking on some very
serious issues the next topic he
broached was these text messages where
we learned that mark meadows trump's
former chief of staff as the
insurrectious coup attempt was going on
he was texting with a variety of fox
news hosts including sean hannity
everybody was kind of giving orders and
strategizing back and forth really no uh
no fresh air between the administration
and fox to speak of and biden commented
on that as well take a
look fox news i'm i'm really sorry
your preferred candidate lost the last
election
to make it up to you i'm happy to give
my chief of staff
to you all so he can tell sean hannity
what to say every day
and then uh the camera cutting to fox
reporter john roberts who genuinely
didn't seem to like that
um fox news
really ridiculed during this but
deservedly so i mean mark meadows was
texting sean hannity and telling him
what to say and it's embarrassing and
it's a joke and it's pathetic so really
nicely done i didn't really care for the
sort of uh um actual uh comedians who
did i just i'm not super into it
although trevor noah did have some funny
lines but biden got a bunch of good
stuff there and these are important
issues and to be perfectly frank there
might be people who aren't even aware
about some of these things because they
don't really watch news but they hear
about this as an entertainment event
maybe they watched it maybe they go text
messages hannity mark meadows what's up
with that let me look that up and go wow
trump's chief of staff was telling sean
hannity what to say that's not exactly
fair and balanced news it's not even
really news or reporting anyway it's
just propaganda
so nice job by joe biden doesn't mean
he's doing any better or worse of a job
as president he just did a nice job at
the white house correspondents dinner
which i generally generally speaking
don't care about but uh did enjoy
watching it this time
the other thing that i have to tell you
i enjoyed watching this weekend and
usually i don't enjoy this
donald trump glitched
very badly causing psychiatric nurses to
email me and to say david
i'm recognizing what's going on with
trump uh so this is this this is this is
pretty serious
um donald trump was scheduled to have a
rally in nebraska on friday evening
there were big storms and so the rally
was postponed until yesterday sunday
and donald trump
truly seemed to have completely lost his
wits he didn't seem to know what was
going on this was a nearly two hour long
it was like a sprawling almost fidel
castro like droning on about nothing
nearly two hours of this stuff
the crowd was as bored as ever and trump
continued to have these brain glitches
making no sense just like
swiss cheese you know mayonnaise is up
there in his skull
my absolute favorite moment and i
tweeted about this right away and it
started trending on twitter and then the
clip ultimately getting millions of
views
trump didn't know who he who he had
endorsed
trump claimed that he endorsed
a non-existent candidate
blending the names of two different
candidates and looking off to the side
saying who did we endorse
this is an incredible moment take a look
at this that's what they're waiting for
they're waiting for one race you know
we've endorsed dr oz we've endorsed
jp right j.d mandel
and he's doing great
[Laughter]
so let me back that up first he says
we've endorsed jp right and he looks
over to the side of jp i don't know
who's jp he says we've endorsed j.d
mandel now this is a blend of two people
who are running against each other in
the ohio republican senate primary jd
vance is one candidate
and josh mandel is another candidate now
it's not just that trump doesn't know
who the hell he endorsed and he makes up
a name of a person that doesn't exist
spent the entire election cycle trying
to get trump's endorsement he didn't get
it
trump goes to jd vance jd vance
basically threw himself at the altar of
trump and said anything he could
apologized for the criticisms of trump
from years ago in order to finally get
trump's endorsement
and then trump ends up mentioning his
opponent
trump ends up mentioning the guy he's
running against by saying j.d mandel two
days before the primary he confuses who
he even endorsed if biden did this
they'd be saying oh we got to remove him
for the 25th amendment he's demented
he's got dementia he can't think
after seeing this i got an email from a
nurse educator who also worked as an
aged care registered nurse
and said this is a quote from from her
i cared for people with dementia for
many years and know a lot about it trump
demonstrates a telling symptom of
dementia called perseverance he says the
same phrases over and over again
everyone knows it's more than has ever
happened before and it's really a shame
he uses the same gestures over and over
again pointing upward making the circle
with the thumb and forefinger he tells
the same stories over and over again he
seems unable to grasp and repeat new
stories in this case this is new stuff
right jd mandel this is these are new
candidates doesn't know what's going on
he uses simple language with restricted
vocabulary he pads his language with
unnecessary phrases he can't speak
specifically only in generalities no one
can diagnose dementia with certainty in
this way but it doesn't look good
um by the way this jd mandelgaf
hasn't appeared on truth social it
hasn't appeared on getter the users on
parlor aren't talking about it fox news
isn't talking about it they'll never
even know that it happened um it
actually it's almost like that time when
trump got obama's name wrong obama you
guys remember that okay so um then just
glitch after glitch after glitch we
there was no actual substance to the
rally so i won't even bore you with it
but then at another point trump glitched
on mit romney's name and you can see
that he kind of has this twitch when he
does it even though it was totally made
up that was about a guy named
a rhino named mitt romney
it's almost quite literally like someone
stopping a record mit rhyme
mitt romney
mitt romney
listen to it once even though it was
totally made up that was about a guy
named a rhino named mitt romney
mitt romney that
is really quite a noise um and then
lastly trying to talk about billy the
kid
i guess talking about billy the kids
bovine counterpart billy the cud this
one is wacky
i've had more investigations than jesse
james billy they could
you really don't know whether to laugh
or cry but this is a guy who seems very
unwell and it's a combination of
weaponized narcissism
it's i don't know what else you know
fidel castro was known castro was known
for four five hour speeches
trump
two hours of trump is as bad as five of
castro i would argue just endlessly
going over a lot of the same stuff crowd
visibly bored
uh and then the glitches the glitches
are just coming so frequently so what's
going on with them i don't know but even
trump now is saying you know it's
possible that health might be a reason i
don't run in 2024.
who knows we're going to keep following
it and uh again for all the people
saying biden doesn't look good if you
look at biden at the white house
correspondents dinner this weekend and
you look at trump talking about j.d
mandel a quite literally imaginary
person
seems pretty clear to me which one's
worse off we'll take a quick break and
be back right after this
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
it's not been a particularly good couple
of weeks for radical trumpist republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor-green she
of course had these incredible hearings
about her involvement in allegedly
inciting the trump riot insurrection
during which she very obviously perjured
herself multiple times lying under oath
she then um was exposed further by some
leaked text messages text messages
involving donald trump's former chief of
staff mark meadows in which she seems to
very clearly be telling him uh you know
people are talking about and maybe we
should look into this whole martial law
thing now hilariously she misspelled
martial law
m-a-r-s-h-a-l-l like the name rather
than
m-a-r-t-i
that's sort of like a
sidebar uh comedy element to the entire
thing
but she was finally confronted about
these text messages uh by cnn reporter
jim acosta he did the ambush thing as i
call it where he just kind of found her
on the street as far as we know now i
want to be open to the possibility
that this was scheduled and this was
just the way it developed where it was
yeah you can talk to me as i walk
between meetings as far as i know this
was sort of like the ambush style and
i'm going to talk about that in a little
bit because i have some thoughts about
that approach but the subject matter
here is fascinating and you might notice
that jim acosta does a really nice touch
here where he mentions the misspelling
of marshall a bunch of times during this
confrontation so pay attention to that
uh notice how marjorie taylor green will
not stop speaking her approach is to try
to not let acosta even get a word in
check it out
i don't seem to recall a whole lot
what's going on there
you know jim
you have a show and and in all fairness
you try to present this image of me to
your viewers and it's just really not
correct well we're just trying to get
some answers did you send a text
asking for the president to declare
martial law did you do that you know i
don't recall those being my text
messages but have you read the text
message that is
that you're referring
so first mention of the misspelling
if you read it correctly jim your
problem is you're lying again right now
it says i do not know on those things
that's what that text message
one of the funniest things that has to
be mentioned is on the one hand she
won't actually own up to it being her
text now of course it is it's her text
there's no dispute about the technical
aspect of it
but she keeps saying the text is being
misrepresented it's like well if you
didn't send it if you're sticking by i
don't even recall that it's my text does
it really matter what it said if it's
not even really your text she wants to
play both sides on it
one of those liars on television and
people hate it they can't see in the
liars on tv i'm not the one saying i
don't recall i don't recall it well the
supposed text message require quote it
what does it say i don't know on those
things if you want to hang on let's read
it out let's read it okay
honest for once and the entire time he's
looking for it she's just badgering him
read it out loud let's take a look i
mean yeah my question is
what does it actually say okay what is
the text message read the whole thing
let's look at it okay let's read it
but you're saying you don't recall it i
don't know if that's my text message or
not but if you want to talk about a text
i don't even know if i said it but you'd
damn well better quote me correctly from
it so that you actually tell people what
i meant
in the text message i don't even know if
i sent message read the text message
do something let's take a look let's
take a look okay read the exact text
messages you're talking about i'll read
it i'll read it let's take a look here
oh we got an article why don't you find
the actual text message
let's see here let's have a second
in our private chat with only members
several are saying the only way to save
our republic is for trump to call for
martial law
marshall was not keep going i don't
i don't know on those things i just
wanted you to tell him i don't know
is that what that says it says i don't
know on those things wait hold on stop
this text message that's supposedly mine
i don't know if it is right jim you're
misquoting me from a text message that
is supposedly mine but i don't know hey
it says some members and then it says
wait hold on it says i don't know wait i
don't know if that's my it says i don't
know on those things why don't you tell
that story you're saying you don't know
you're lying
you're defensive about
so um the constant talking to try to
prevent him from actually getting a word
in that's a technique that's often used
it's the same technique she used in the
debate last night at the top of the show
we covered some of the georgia elections
that are going on one of them is
marjorie taylor green's republican
primary
she had her mic cut yesterday at a
debate or the day before the cl i found
the clip yesterday maybe it was from the
day before
she had her mic cut because she wouldn't
stop talking
okay so this is a strategy that she
employs it's a technique a tactic i
guess we would say she also
simultaneously doesn't recall whether
it's actually her text message but is
mad that what she meant to say is being
misinterpreted how do you know what you
meant to say if it's not even clear you
sent the message if i say i don't know
whether i wrote it
how can i know
what the intention of the writer is
if it's me i would know but i'm saying i
don't actually remember it's full-on
double speak now let me talk a little
bit about ambush style let's assume that
this was ambush style meaning jim acosta
just kind of found her was waiting for
her showed up with a camera
it's not a tactic i use and the reason i
don't do it is
it doesn't strike me as fair as a
general thing we have an interview
process and sometimes people decline to
be interviewed
and i don't like that but i respect it
in the sense that i can't compel some
the same way that i can't compel harvard
to allow me to speak there right we have
these conservatives often say i'm being
silenced because a school won't have me
for an event it's like well though they
don't have to
people don't have to speak to me so for
me
if i request an interview request an
interview people don't want to do it for
me to then show up and kind of ambush
them to me it doesn't feel like the
right thing to do however however
i am sensitive to an explanation that
sometimes is given for using the
technique for people in positions of
power which is
they are in a position of power
they have legislative authority in this
case they can be involved in making law
all these different they're supposed to
be accountable to the people
and they won't answer real basic
questions about
are are you lying are you telling lies
what's going on here when you say you
don't recall but then here's the text is
it yours and they won't sit down and
actually be questioned
you can make the case that reporters are
left with no choice so there are
circumstances where if it's truly a
reporter and someone in a position of
power i get having no other option it's
not a technique i use but i can see both
sides of the discussion let me know what
you think about the technique send me
your thoughts and maybe we'll do a
follow-up on the ambush technique
i want to do just a brief interlude here
about my pillow ceo mike lindell this is
actually very interesting what's going
on
because it's bigger than pillow this is
about twitter
with the room it's not even really a
rumor with the news that in principle
elon musk is going to be buying twitter
although it's not been approved it may
fall apart and to be perfectly frank i'm
a little bit more and more and more in
the direction of this may this may never
happen but that's a story for a
different day there are lots of right
wingers that are sort of reinvigorated
who have been banned from twitter who
believe they're sure they're going to be
back on twitter that elon personally is
going to allow them back on twitter one
such person is my pillow ceo mike
lindell known colloquially as mike
pillow or just pillow for short
he
decided to evade his ban
by creating a new account and it lasted
three hours now remember even if elon
musk plans to unban pillow which we have
no reason to think uh at least at this
point
elon musk is not in control right now a
business insider reporting lindell was
banned from twitter in 2021 over
election misinformation but rejoined the
platform sunday
the account was quickly banned for
violating twitter's ban evasion policy
jack dorsey should be first in line for
prison
lindell told insider business insider
via text
uh
hello everybody i'm back on twitter he
tweeted my only account is mike j
lindell
please retweet
follow to spread the word
the tweet also featured a video of
pillow confirming the account is his all
those other ones are fake accounts and
they've been using my name out there so
we started this account
please share it with everybody let
everybody know so we can get the word
out at twitter in case in case they do
take it down thanks a lot for helping
out
three and a half hours later the account
was suspended so twitter has what's
called a ban evasion policy and if
you've been banned you're not allowed to
attempt to evade it by making a similar
account like if my d pacman account was
banned it's not just the account it's me
as a person that is banned and we can
like it or we cannot like it and i'll
talk about that in a second i can't they
then go and create
dave pakman and if twitter finds out
that that's actually me uh of course
they they would be within their terms of
service to ban me again now i do want to
say something about these twitter bans
i am sensitive to the idea
that maybe there shouldn't be bans for
life
i i i could be convinced of that uh i
think that the trump ban was completely
correct and legitimate i think that um
the lindell ban was completely correct
and legitimate but
i would be open to the idea that the
maximum ban is a five-year ban or a
three-year ban i mean people do change
and i'm not saying trump will change but
also what's acceptable changes and great
examples are like on youtube
policies around many issues have changed
over time early in covet there was one
policy on covet material later it was
different um
i i could go on you can get the the idea
it's sort of in a way i mean
this isn't a serious i'm being honest
it's not a serious but
when when you
more seriously there are people doing
time for drug possession
and later
the penalties for drug possession are
reduced
or possession is decriminalized or
possession is legalized
and i think that that should be subject
to review and that's why i like it when
joe biden and others have kind of gone
back and exonerated or commuted
sentences on that basis so
i think there's a good case to be made
that the lifetime ban on twitter maybe
is a bit much maybe it should be three
years maybe five years or something like
that it is not currently the case and of
course pillow is evading the ban one
other thing on mike pillow here he was
interviewed at yesterday's trump rally
he says that he's spending 18 hours a
day on this trump reinstatement stuff
that's wild dominion and machines a
machine and uh you know it's been a it's
been a crazy year and a half but uh how
has your life changed personally i know
your business like and we'll get to that
special promotion you have for us in a
second but how has your personal life
changed since all of this i mean it's 18
hours a day where you know i miss my
grandkids i miss my family you know and
uh and my niece and nephews we i gotta
take you know take advantage of when i
can but it's uh before i was i'm so in
the family it's like i'm pulled away
from my home state of minnesota he's
spending 18 hours a day going around
talking about machines we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines and claiming that we're just a
week away from it all coming out that
that actually makes me a little bit sad
it really does i not because pillow's a
particularly good guy
uh but there's something a little bit
sad about that we have a voicemail
number that number is
david p
here is our friend the troll man asking
a question which uh does not understand
burden of proof listen to this
hey david it's juan
i know this question is probably going
to sound trollish
maybe it is i don't know yeah
so you say that
republicans
get caught committing
voter fraud right possibly because
they're not very smart
would that mean i actually didn't say
that i said republicans are the ones who
keep getting caught committing the voter
fraud even though they're the ones who
say it's the left that's doing it the
democrats could be committing voter
fraud but aren't getting caught because
they are smart
it's just the question
the reason i ask it is because
i find it unreasonable or illogical
or
almost impossible
for there not to be at least one case of
a democrat
committing voter fraud yeah there are
isolated you can find a case of a
democrat committing voter fraud this is
what's called a special pleading and a
misplaced burden of proof and so the
example that i often will give is
someone comes to you and they say sir
david there's a uh there's an elephant
in the room with you right now as you
are doing the show and i would say okay
well usually when there's an elephants
are big i don't see an elephant they go
well
is it possible the elephant's invisible
okay maybe the elephant's invisible let
me put down some baby powder because
certainly if there's an elephant in here
that's invisible as they walk around
they or breathe they will move some of
the baby powder and they go no because
not only is it invisible it's weightless
and it's suspended in the air so it's
not going to move around the baby powder
and i go okay well you know what let let
me do this let me throw a ball
and if there's really an elephant here
then the ball will bounce out they go no
because it's also it's a special
elephant where
matter can pass through it and you keep
adding at some point the burden of proof
has to be on you to prove that there's
an elephant in the room and similarly
here
the the republicans insist that
democrats are the ones committing voter
fraud
it's almost never happening but
anecdotally it's republicans that keep
getting caught
so then to come back and say well
is it possible that it's really
democrats mostly committing it but
they're smarter and committing it better
so they're not getting caught well at
some point the burden has to be on you
to prove that
the fact that republicans just insist
democrats are committing voter fraud
absent any evidence at some point you
have to prove your hypothesis about
what's going on all right trollman
please and thank you we have a great
bonus show for you today uh russia may
be bracing uh for a default and and
rapidly approaching one we will talk
about the impact it may have
connecticut has passed a bill to make
the state a safe haven for abortion
providers the opposite of what's
happening in oklahoma as we talked about
earlier and joe biden's support among
gen z and millennials is collapsing why
is it collapsing we will talk about it
and more on today's bonus show please
sign up at joinpackman.com
to get instant access to the bonus show
you'll also get the daily show six hours
earlier than everybody else when you are
a member sign up at joinpacman.com we
will see you then